it is march 26 2022 and you're watching
the code report i use arch by the way
it's a phrase reserved for the most
elite and disciplined linux users and is
completely off limits to all of us soy
devs on our macbook pros until now
because just last week a new linux
distro called asahi has brought the
linux experience to apple silicon i
couldn't believe it myself so i did some
investigative developing and dropped two
grand on a macbook pro to try it out for
this video what i found was absolutely
shocking
it actually worked somewhat okay for the
most part apple silicon has been a game
changer in the computing world which
uses bleeding edge technology to create
blazingly fast chips with the arm
architecture and blazingly fast is no
exaggeration here they're literally the
most powerful consumer chips on the
market there's just one small problem
like everything in apple they live
within a walled garden which means you
can really only run mac os on those
chips primarily because it's missing
drivers to do anything useful and
there's virtually no documentation to
figure things out however everything
we're doing here is perfectly legal and
there's no jailbreaking involved it's
not like ios where the bootloader is
locked down to prevent you from loading
another operating system on it m1
macbooks give you access to the
bootloader but don't expect a great
developer experience working with it
asahi means rising sun in japanese not
to be confused with the beer of the same
name it comes from a team with a lot of
experience bringing linux to weird
places like the playstation it just had
its first alpha release a few days ago
so buckle up for the asahi linux
experience first my mom took me to the
local apple store so i could use my
birthday money to purchase a macbook pro
with a state-of-the-art m1 chip after
that we had lunch at the olive garden
when i got home i opened it and
immediately entered the command to
install asahi linux git wasn't installed
so it recommended i install xcode which
took a couple of hours once that was
done i tried again but then needed to
update my system to mac os monterey that
took another couple of hours once that
was done the command finally worked when
you start it up it will take you through
a variety of options but most
importantly it will make a partition on
your hard drive to install a completely
separate operating system what you'll
end up with is a dual boot system with
mac os on one side and linux on the
other the entire process took about a
half hour and i just went with the
default options most importantly at the
end it gives you instructions about how
to boot up the system you'll need to
hold down the power button for 15
seconds which will eventually bring you
to a screen with multiple boot options
choose asahi and it will bring you into
arch running the kde plasma desktop it
also comes with a setup wizard which is
basically cheating if you want to call
yourself an arch user but it's a much
easier way to get started which is
cheating if you want to call yourself an
arch user i installed node.js and played
around with some javascript and
everything seemed to work perfectly fine
i didn't do any benchmarking but my
friend alex has a great channel for
stuff like that i did have problems
running vs code but it does come with
vim out of the box and there's a whole
list of things that are known not to
work at this point things like the gpu
and neural engine which means you can't
really take full advantage of the apple
silicon chips just yet still it's a very
impressive project and most importantly
i can now say i use arch by the way
without being a total poser i even had
14 dollars of birthday money left over
so i went out and got myself an arch
tattoo this has been the code report
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one